[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
the UK general election with a predicted
large majority this would be the biggest
majority for the Tories since the days
of Margaret Thatcher and Labour's were
showing in about 80 years it would seem
getting breaks it done did the trick
this is a big win for Bojo but is it for
the UK
[Music]
crosstalking the UK general election I'm
joined by my guest John white in embryo
he's a political commentator and writer
in London we have Mitch Firestein he's a
candidate for the UK Parliament fund
manager and author also in London we
cross to Alan skid is a professor
emeritus of international history at the
London School of Economics
all right crosstalk rules in effect that
means you can jump in anytime you want
and I always appreciate Mitch let me go
to you first in London what happened the
poles told us something very differently
going into this here I have to say in my
opinion from my distant perch to be
honest I found both the Tories and
labour I ran a lackluster campaigns but
I have to admit one thing is that talk
the Tory message get Briggs it done did
resonate because I still I don't even
remember what the Labour slogan was it
was that muddy muddled and vague okay
why this result and Bojo Boris Johnson
the sitting Prime Minister must be a
very happy man go ahead Mitch you know I
think there are a lot of interesting
components to what happened today I mean
you know I was on campaign on the
campaign trail for probably five or six
months going into this with the brexit
party and getting breaks it done was an
important message that Boris got out the
problem that we had was briggsie
exhaustion and people didn't want to
hear about Briggs's yeah
the bigger issue was after three and a
half years like 1278 days ago the 17
point four million of the country voted
to leave and 75% of the parliamentarians
said we really don't care what you voted
and we're going to usurp democracy and
not let you have a brexit and then Boris
came up with a bunch of sharp sound
bites like I'm gonna get braig's it done
I'm gonna do it right away I'm gonna die
in a ditch he didn't die in a ditch he
didn't get Bragg's it done on October
31st he's made a lot of promises and his
latest ones were that got him over the
line were we have a new oven-baked
Bragg's a deal now a couple of things
that I would say about that his deal is
not new it's 95 percent to resumes
terrible treaty it's not oven-ready
it's half-baked and it's not Briggs it
in its four current form so I you know I
think that those are the topics we can
start out yeah and you know if you want
to get into into the weeds on what
happened with the election I can get
into as much detail as you like with the
strategies but Nigel Farage handed the
Tory Party 317 seats we actually
diminished Labour's seats and we got rid
of pretty much the Liberal Democrats
okay let's look at the results here I
mean is this a protest vote because it
is unprecedented here I mean and how to
explain Labor's uttered devastating
defeat in this election year I mean this
we're going back to the 1930s here with
this kind of result how do you explain
it Alan go ahead in London well I think
there two reasons first of all Coburn
had no coherent policy on prexy he
didn't want to say whether he was for or
against and people did want the result
of the referendum to be implemented
secondly his policies is of neo-marxist
Marxist Leninist view of the economy we
seen his absolutely frightening or
incredible and people didn't pay much
attention to it and they thought it
would be backfire and probably ruin the
economy so on both fronts the economic
front and the brakes upfront nobody was
willing to listen to him very much and
he ended up with this dire outcome for
labour which goes back to about 1935
yeah I'm not to take if she was the
first speaker though about the brakes of
party it should never have stood in the
election its campaign promises were
hollow and if it didn't crush the Lib
Dem so tables from neighbor it's ended
up giving labour seats that the
Conservatives and the brexit
Conservative Party should have gone it's
all just an ego trip by the leader Nigel
Farage who with any luck will not be
consigned to history okay we'll talk a
little bit about that later in the
program John jump in here how do you
explain this outcome here because I tend
to think too though I want to talk about
how the media framed this entire
election because I think the media put
its thumb on the scales as usual go
ahead John the result of this election
entirely hinged on whether Corbin's
message of hope is message that the
condition of working-class people did
not have to be purgatory or hell that
cruelty did not have to be a virtue
compassion advice after ten years of
total insanity whether that message
managed to penetrate the fog of emotion
surrounding praxis is particularly in
northern and Midlands belieber marginals
and unfortunate for him and for his
supporters it did not resonate but when
you consider no but John job but why
didn't it resonate I think that's an
important quote why didn't it resonate
because basically Boris Johnson was
running on almost a decade of Tory rule
so this should have been a change
election but it wasn't explained that go
ahead Joe well I differ from your rocky
Toshiro breaks it
Corbin's policy on brakes it was the
most politically and intellectually
honest of any party because they started
with recognition that the country was
split on the middle fifty two percent
versus forty percent voted in the 2016
EU referendum but breaks emotional
breaks that was far more powerful than
carbon and labor actually recognized
because it's a question of identity it's
a question of what it means to be
British it's a question of democracy and
also and this is something that's very
important every saying you of the
transitory establishment was brought to
begin against Corbin media analytical
three years every single D the character
assassination this man has been
subjected to arena did there was no
remarkable that he would go down to such
a crushing defeat in this election okay
how and you wanted to say something
there do you agree or disagree with what
you just heard from John go ahead
Corbin's policy was thought to be
ridiculous I mean he said he would
really go said ideal which the EU didn't
want to renegotiate
he said he would then put in a rigged
referendum to the people but he wouldn't
actually back the deal that there our
friend him was that he had must be sad
okay again appear which isn't until
lianna's this intellectually stupid and
again you know the reason why the
working-class wouldn't believe his
claims on reversing austerity warns that
the austerity came in to reverse the
mess that the Labour Party had left the
country in 2015 so in 2010 and any
Labour leader that goes to the country
in Britain with a left-wing Marxist
policy is always radically defeated
haven't Michel food it happened to the
Labour Party in 1935 the British people
aren't interested in warmed up communism
okay Mitch go ahead jump in you were
about to say something go ahead I think
yeah I think that's a I think that's a
bit of an oversimplification and I would
disagree with Alan's points at mostly on
on the way that he said that things
rolled out Nigel Farage is the only
reason why we had a referendum to begin
with a bigger problem is we don't have
democracy in the United case we don't
have democracy I didn't interrupt you so
let me let me speak we don't have
democracy in the United Kingdom we have
an Oleg our key the problem with
Corbin's platform was he was offering
free stuff and it just wasn't credible
at all whatsoever and if you look at all
the things that they were offering it
would have run the economy into a ditch
a lot faster than Boris's the reason why
we had austerity was because it back in
2008 the Bank of England decided to bail
out our banks and that's when the
currency dropped 34% so that's why we
have austerity because they cut back on
the spending and that's why they cut the
police force by 22,000 that's why they
implemented all these other cuts and
then you have an increase you've got an
increase in the population and a
decrease in the services so that's going
to end a disaster and then they the
media kept pounding and pounding away
crash out brags it no deal brags it yeah
crash out brags it breaks it breaks it
so people were fed up and exhausted and
he came up with the perfect soundbite
created in America get Bragg's it done
I'm gonna get it done it's oven-baked so
they just said okay get it done and get
it off the plate and let's move forward
the problem and a big
he's promised a magnificent economic
recovery which is just not going to
happen and people are gonna realize down
the road I don't know if it's two years
a year when he defaults on his promises
again okay well let's talk about the
promises in the second half of the
program here John I want to make it very
clear on this program and I want to hear
it from you do you think how do you feel
the media treated labor and Jeremy
during this campaign because it looked
like one smear after another okay and it
looks like again they had their thumb on
the scale go ahead John let's go let's
go to John and Admiral go ahead John the
demonization of Jeremy Corbyn has been
unprecedented even worse than any
earlier labor leader including Harold
Wilson in 1874 your viewers may not be
aware of the most important that was up
for to actually topple Harold Wilson and
a coup with Lohrman ban as the interim
prime minister and so Corbin got even
worse treatment and as he was treated to
real enemy of the people stuff in the
Tory press he was seen as an enemy
within the spacious campaigns depicted
him as an anti-semite this allotment
tending jam-making quicker a socialist
was depicted as the second coming of
reinhard heydrich and so the the media
stream of jeremy corbyn was utterly
despicable over these past three years
it was incitement and yet despite us
movies of people still supported them so
me for me the wonder is the ego as many
words as he received in this election
but let me just caution these Union Jack
waving Rule Britannia down Buster song
singing blacks at bomba deals from
celebrating too much because as I speak
pizza the Train of Scottish independent
has already left ok ok I want you to
hold on I want you to hold on to that
thought because that's exactly what I
want to do in this second part of the
program
alright gentlemen we're gonna go to a
short break and after that short break
but there's so much more to cover on
this election when to talk about
Scotland and with a talk if Boris
Johnson can actually affect
brexit after a short break we continue
our discussion on the UK general
election stay with our team
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered on Peter labelled
to remind you were discussing the UK
general election
[Music]
okay let's go back to Alan in in London
in the introduction of the program I
said this is a big win a big victory for
Boris Johnson but is it a big victory
for the UK because at the latter part of
the first part of the program we we
talked about the specter of another
Scottish independence vote and and Boris
Johnson after he repels the his cabinet
on Monday he has the task of Briggs
ahead which he ran on can he affect that
and how difficult will it be with the
Europeans because it takes to to parlay
go ahead Alan oh you could certainly do
it he has the part of it majority to
accomplish it the Europeans were making
positive noises there they want a quick
deal because they're fed up with brexit
as well some Europeans are saying
different things but on the whole you
could certainly get our basic free trade
treaty done by almost immediately if he
wants to change
I get more flexibility they might take a
little bit longer you might just go for
no deals so Breck sir will certainly
happen there's you mention Scottish
independence the latest opinion poll in
Scotland says that 56% want to remain in
the United Kingdom and 44% want
independence so I I don't think we need
way too much about that would win and
I'm Scottish
we would win the referendum again Nicola
Sturgeon would lose again and in any
case this could have a huge trial in
Scotland starting in March of the former
SNP leader and First Minister who's
accused of attempted rape and 13 other
sexual assault charges and his defense
is going to be as a stitch-up caused by
Nicola Sturgeon so the SNP movement is
about to divide Harper Lee when that
trial starts so Boris will just say no
we don't want a lifetime expectation of
the first result and there's no evidence
that opinion has shifted a Nicola
Sturgeon has to keep her militants happy
so she talks about a second referendum
all the
time but she's not gonna get it okay
John weigh in on that Scott another
independence vote go ahead John oh the
base figure for support for Scottish
independence are called to the post with
recent polls that are in the high 40s
which is historically the highest for
middle 40 if you consider that when I
examined the then leader of the SNP
called the referendum in 2014 when he
called it into a desert in the baseline
forged in support of independence was
just over 30 percent then you're looking
at something that is quite remarkable
happening in Scotland yes that is a very
controversial high court case coming
down the track for the SNP and much
concerning I'll examine but the Scottish
independence is far far bigger than the
SNP and this result is the biggest boon
to the fortunes of Scottish independence
and this country can no longer be and
can no longer be superseded by anything
to do with any kind of UK identity
Scotland the inevitability of Scotland
independence cannot be gainsaid pizza is
coming down the track it's happening and
less than affecting I can say it's it's
2016 just expect the unexpected okay and
don't believe the polls okay the polls
you know I mean you know that they they
fail us time and again in and that's why
I stay away from them let me go to Mitch
let me go to Mitch right now Mitch the
fate of Jeremy Corbyn right now I mean
he's he's definitely on the out okay
this is a deplorable outcome for his
party but let me give you an observation
again for my faraway perch you're there
obviously he never really led why isn't
that why was it be able to lead the
Labour Party okay
and I actually have personal sympathy
towards him I don't agree with his
policies I think he's an a straight-up
guy honest guy
old-school okay someone a conservative
like me can understand someone like him
a lot of other people in politics they
have no clue what they're talking about
so I'm trying to be gentle here but at
the same time he didn't he didn't leave
and I think that is one of his greatest
failures let me go to Mitch on this one
go ahead Mitch oh yeah I think that's a
big problem we don't we have a lack of
leadership in the United Kingdom right
now and I don't think there has been a
clear and decisive leader we've had
sound bites and and we've had we've had
sound bites from everybody but we've had
no decisive leadership we've had people
telling making lots of promises but a
lot of them are unaffordable and
undeliverable and not going to be on the
timeframe or the scope scale and
magnitude of which they were promised
going back to korban when he was asked
what he was gonna do about brexit he had
one foot in one foot yeah not putting a
commitment on because he didn't want to
alienate the 5,000,000 labour voters who
he had to throw under the bus to say he
was going to have a second referendum
where your choices would be remain or
remain so you know that wasn't really
giving people an option it was and
people were a little fed up and I saw
tonight when we were counting ballots
tonight I saw so many spoiled ballot
papers where people had written in on
the ballot papers I can't trust any of
you you're all a bunch of liars you
don't try you don't represent us the
people are fed up there are
unprecedented levels of anger across
this country there is intolerance right
and this is the most extreme
polarization we've seen in this country
ever and I think the media has whipped
up that frenzy to even higher levels you
know we're rapidly running out of having
Alan you know during this whole brexit
saga we saw the failings of both parties
we saw the problems that the the Jeremy
Corbyn had with labour and keeping his
party united and we also saw that with
Tresemme with the Tories but it looks
like Boris Johnson has will have a
United Party but the it's labour now
that's going to be in a leadership
contest that will tear it apart okay so
Boris Johnson last-man-standing go ahead
Alan that's absolutely right the Tory
party will now be solid to the United
behind Boris who's pulled off I get a
political miracle tonight labour will be
Leyton two or three different ways the
Lib Dems are irrelevant the brexit part
is even more irrelevant so Boris is a
huge opportunity to remake the British
political scene in his own image and he
will he's a historic figure okay John
how do you reflect upon that because
we're in a new era right now I have to
say and it's because I I have no choice
but to look at the polls but I'm so
disappointed again with the polls
because it looked like it was a lot
tighter but it looks like a genuine
mandate from the people that did vote go
ahead John well show me a mandate from
the people of England and we should meet
that's the point that's fair point
opinion polls are less to do with
measuring public opinion more to do with
trying to influence at PETA and they
should be consigned to the dustbin of
history they have got a classic stroke
of catastrophic control in the last few
years the people are deep for hope and
they voted for despair I never won
another long name of Tory barbarism
descends and the last ten years of
austerity 120,000 people have died as a
direct result and the same deck in the
same decade as a thousand richest people
so their combined wealth increased by
one over one hundred eighty percent and
Boris Johnson is a figure to ever occupy
down Russia
this man is a serial liar is a charlatan
and he is so low that he could get under
the snakes barely wearing a top hat and
get still people voted for this man why
because as I say the emotional break set
is so powerful that no other kind of
program could penetrate that fog jeremy
corbyn i think is a great man I think he
has been he has been treated as such
he's an unsaved mindful in extremis 260
because he was afraid to see this for
war against the pure home and war
against poor countries overseas it's
okay the dust is settling right now what
is Boris Johnson have to do to succeed
give me a checklist three things go
ahead Mitch he's got it he's got to get
rid of this thinking problems with with
withdrawal agreement he's got to get the
brexit free-trade agreements negotiated
as he promised by the end of next year
which the European Union says they won't
get done and he's got to deliver on
improving policing because crime is a
real big problem in this country one one
one thing that I must add here is
Scotland although you want to have
independence I don't know how you're
gonna pay for it because the European
Union has said that they your finances
won't allow it without Westminster
support so Boris is in a unique
situation I think what we've need to do
also is have proportional representation
and this vote showed that
first-past-the-post is garbage and it
doesn't really represent all of the
people and it's a non-functioning
archaic system that needs to be changed
okay Aled has turned out to be the mr.
contrary and on this program that's why
I like having him on you were shaking
your head go right ahead
yeah I mean that the first-past-the-post
system means that Britain has the early
Parliament in Europe hasn't gotten
extremely extreme parties in it well
with the exception of Corbin and his
Marxist Leninist extremists now
anti-semites around at the top of the
Labor Party but we don't have right-wing
extremists in our Parliament which is
unique in Europe Parliament's all over
Europe are full of extremists but not
the British one and that's due to the
first-past-the-post system if we got PR
like God knows we'd end up like full of
loonies just like the European
Parliament's okay John what does Labour
do now okay as the dust settles here
when will Jeremy step aside I probably
assume he will stay in Parliament but
when a when and will he step aside in
what do you do you think will replace
him or who's in the running at least go
ahead John he's already announced that
he intends to design I think I'll resign
most immediately the Labour Party will
move back towards the center and it will
be taking the character of what people
have been accustomed to expecting from
is that is that is that a winning
proposition going back to the centre
because I know a lot of people and the
Labour Party that's not what they want
to do it's it's very much like the
Democrats in the United States they're
tearing themselves down the middle keep
going John absolutely no dissent took
the political center ground Peter house
collapse it collapsed because the
neoliberal economic model it sustains a
house
collapsed in the wake of the 2008
economic crash financial an economic
crash but the Labour Party will move
towards the center they will feel that's
where they should be the blanks will
come to the fore again and hope will be
removed from British politics two
million people registered to vote pizza
when this election was called as a
record in British politics many of them
are young people and many were inspired
to register to vote by Jeremy Corbyn so
as I say I think hope has been removed
from British politics the NHS it's now
in peril anything good in this country
is never peddle and we will go back to
the business as usual when it comes to
politics we'll go back to the convicted
and spun politicians or people of a tank
well-known and any chance of
authenticity and honesty in politics
there's no I got in here when it comes
to Boris Johnson it's never business as
usual all right that's all the time we
have many thanks to my guest in
Edinburgh and in London and thanks to
our viewers for watching us here at RT
see you next time and remember crossbuck
rules
[Music]